from laughable endings to gratuitous
violence to one of Nick Cage's most
iconic performances the reasons are
endless for why audiences gave these
movies a failing grade with the movie 10
Bo Derek exploded onto moviegoers radar
as both a sex symbol and an actor watch
she even managed to score a Golden Globe
nomination for her work in the film
which was only her second acting credit
there were high expectations for where
Derek would go next as a performer
though she never quite got back to that
level of exciting momentum by 1984 she
was already headlining box office Duds
like Bolero which was so despised by
moviegoers that had scored an F rating
from audiences in the nascent years of
Cinema scores existence
[Music]
there were countless reasons why Bolero
was torn to shreds by the general public
though its run time of 104 minutes could
be a key culprit not that a movie that's
less than two hours long should be
considered extensive in any normal case
but bolero's plot line which concerns a
woman seeking out the perfect person to
take her virginity and stretched far
past the breaking point
[Music]
the most precious flower
the blooming can only be enjoyed what it
doesn't help that Bolero also has an
incredibly stiff and straight laced tone
with no room for the kind of inadvertent
comedy that makes something like the
room such cult classic
moviegoer is trapped in a theater
watching Bolero were simply bored by
what was on screen rather than
unintentionally amused by it in the end
the film ended up winning six Razzie
Awards unsurprisingly it was five more
years before Bo Derek returned to the
Silver Screen with another star vehicle
after this debacle as the 20th century
was drawing to a close the second film
ever to score an F Cinema score grade
finally arrived the project that scored
this dubious honor was the 1999 Stephen
Elliott Thriller Eye of the Beholder
headlined by Ewan McGregor and Ashley
Judd the film saw McGregor portraying a
spy who follows the serial killer across
the United States of course the twist is
that he ends up forming an attachment to
her it's a story that employs several
uses of inexplicable imagery and
narrative turns all in the hope of
creating an atmosphere that would leave
audiences unsure of where it was going
next in the process I the beholder just
created an atmosphere that audiences
hated the creepy behavior on the part of
McGregor's protagonist which Elliot
often plays off his sweet or Tender
undoubtedly put off viewers as well as
the strange cinematography that leaves
Eye of the Beholder visually
incomprehensible in some spots plus all
the ambiguity resulted in a slow feature
that failed to deliver the Thrills
moviegoers were looking for no wonder
this Ewan McGregor vehicle became only
the second 20th Century movie to get the
dread in half in his career director
Robert Altman was responsible for some
of the most acclaimed movies of all time
titles like Nashville and McCabe and Mrs
Miller have become indisputable classic
since they debuted while even more
divisive projects like Popeye have major
cult followings
a director of this ambitious is bound to
produce something that resonates with
people even when he fails to deliver a
new masterpiece however one of the more
disposable entries in his vast
filmography was his 2000 directorial
effort Dr T in the women which paired up
Richard Gere with an All-Star Supporting
Cast of ladies ranging from Helen Hunt
to Lord Dern among many others women are
by Nature they are Saints the sacred
they should be treated as such none of
those performances were able to win over
General moviegoers who branded Dr T and
the women with an F Cinema score grade
part of the issue was that this feature
was marketed as a star-studded romantic
comedy it was actually a more tonally
complicated movie that went down some
truly absurd narrative Avenues the sign
of Richard Gere driving into a tornado
may have satisfied Altman on the set but
it resulted in a feature whose final 30
minutes left a sour taste in the battles
of baffled moviegoers plus the peculiar
tone of the movie which struggled to
balance lightness with darker Concepts
divided critics and alienated the
general public chalk this one up as a
strangely sizable misfire for a legend
like Robert Altman as a cinematographer
yanish Kaminsky has a filmography that's
tough to beat a go-to collaborator with
Steven Spielberg starting with
Schindler's List in 1993. Kaminsky has
an avalanche of iconic movies under his
belt ranging from Jerry Maguire to the
diving bell and the Butterfly among many
others however this Talent didn't quite
translate to his debut as a director in
2000 with the horror feature lost souls
bestowed with an upgrade by audiences
kaminsky's work on Lost Souls is
dreadfully bereft of memorable scenes
the kiss of death or any mainstream
horror film I'm going in with you you
wouldn't last five minutes moviegoers
will tolerate a lot in the pursuit of
Rights like contrived plot points or
Stilton acting but a deficit of scares
is impossible to overcome plus lost
souls delivers an ending that drops one
big twist after another before
concluding in a very abrupt manner while
a solid ending wouldn't have fixed every
problem in Lost Souls it certainly would
have sent audiences out of the theater
on a much more satisfied note
unsurprisingly after helming a film that
got such toxic Buzz Kaminsky has largely
stuck to cinematography in the decades
since everything typically even the
lowest rated comedies have redeeming
qualities look at Bucky Larson born to
be a star as critically Savaged as it
was it still earned a B cinema score
grade from audiences however not every
comedy is impervious to this phenomenon
such as the 2000 John Travolta and Lisa
Kudrow flop lucky numbers am I the only
one who misses our old pal Jack Frost
temperatures
this feature was especially reviled by
the public because it's a misguided stab
at a dark comedy a genre that can become
insufferably mean-spirited if done
poorly some critics were so confused by
its tone that they couldn't even
categorize it Roger Ebert wrote at the
time of its release is it intended as a
comedy or not I ask because there are
funny things in it and then gruesome
things sad things and brutal things
Quentin Tarantino was able to cover that
spread in Pulp Fiction but Nora Ephron
doesn't find a way the film's cinema
score grade was also likely exacerbated
by John Travolta being an especially
ripe punching bag in 2000 thanks to the
then recent failure of Battlefield Earth
a perfect storm of actors swirled around
lucky numbers to make it the rare comedy
that's so bad and earned an effort
horror films can often be dismissed as
junk food Cinema but that's giving the
genre an incredibly insulting short
shrift scary movies have the power to be
Vivid reflections of the anxieties of a
specific era they're just as capable of
Illuminating the inner psyche of General
moviegoers as they are being low budget
stabs at easy cash of course not every
horror feature that attempts to be
relevant lives up to its potential take
the 2002 title fear.com which aimed to
be The Nightmare on Elm Street for a
generation of moviegoers raised on AOL
dial-up an ideal execution of this
premise could have delivered a horror
film that spoke profoundly to those
living in the internet age unfortunately
fear.com missed the mark on that front
one weird element about the film in
hindsight is how much of its horror
hinges on vicious torture sequences two
years before Saul made that style of
scares much more mainstream fear.com was
too ahead of the curve in this regard
and the emphasis on such brutality just
wasn't what audiences were hungry for
yet plus its final 30 minutes are packed
with contrived twists that turn the
whole film into a ludicrous farce albeit
it's an unfunny one the 2002 feature
Solaris was held by Steven Soderbergh
and functioned as a new adaptation of
the stanislav Lem novel of the same name
which was previously turned into a
picture by filmmaker Andre tarkovsky
Solaris has a certain pedigree that was
only enhanced by the presence of George
Clooney in the lead role with such
prominent names all connected to the
feature one would expect Solaris to at
least be competent after all is said and
done instead Solaris was despised by
viewers
what's wrong shortly after the film's
release Clooney opened up to the Seattle
Times to divulge his frustrations over
how Solaris was marketed specifically he
found that every ad or trailer for the
Sci-Fi title felt totally disconnected
from the final product misleading
marketing campaigns often Inspire Anger
from moviegoers as people prefer to get
exactly what they were promised on a
poster when they sit down to watch a
movie plus the extremely glacial pacing
of the project was always bound to be
divisive even if the marketing campaign
had been perfect usually the only
projects at farewell after taking
forever to be released are huge
Blockbusters that Mega fans enjoy
stewing on for long periods of time and
we can all agree that Solaris does not
fit into that category whatsoever
unfortunately the title of Darkness does
not refer to its humorous use in a song
sung by Lego Batman in The Lego Movie
instead darkness is a 2004 horror film
that most of us either forgot or never
knew existed
here the door
what do you mean it eats my pencils the
future had spent years in limbo when it
came to getting released outside of its
Home Country thanks to North American
distributor Miramax engaging in severe
editing to make it more marketable a
tragically common practice for many
foreign titles acquired by Miramax
Darkness ended up losing around 14
minutes of footage when all the trimming
was done the behind the scenes turmoil
is important to consider when grappling
with just how reviled Darkness turned
out to be by General audiences
inevitably the cut released to North
American moviegoers was so jarringly
edited and incoherent that it irritated
audiences instead of terrifying them
it's also yet another horror movie that
concludes on an open-ended note that
suggests terrible things will eventually
happen to our lead characters but
doesn't offer a concrete resolution
after sitting through so much
impenetrable storytelling audiences
wanted something more satisfyingly
definitive this makes it unsurprising
that Darkness was given an f grade by
audiences though it does provide an
ironic finish to a feature whose
post-production was plagued by Studio
interference to make it more audience
friendly
if one is talking about the most reviled
movies of the 21st century it's only a
matter of time before director UVA Bool
enters the conversation a staple of 2000
genre Cinema Bulls films were Infamous
for inexplicable casting choices like
Burt Reynolds showing up in the period
peace fantasy film In The Name of the
King a Dungeon Siege tale an atrocious
dialogue that inspires unintentional
fits of Giggles from viewers among his
early notorious Works was alone in the
dark a video game adaptation that
dropped into theaters in January 2005.
this Motion Picture proved to be
dreadful for some artsier movies it's a
very nuanced process breaking down the
reasons the future was so rejected by
General moviegoers in the case of alone
in the dark the explanation is fairly
simple it's just not very good it begins
with a lengthy opening text crawl that's
read aloud to the viewer these artifacts
speak of terrifying creatures that
thrive in the darkness waiting for the
day when the gate can be opened again
this unintentionally hilarious choice is
followed up by a barrage of compounding
editing and screenwriting that ranks up
with worst entries in terms of baffling
ineptitude when people bought a ticket
to a loan in the dark they just wanted
to watch some sci-fi horror Carnage for
a few hours what they got instead was an
unintentional comedy that fans have been
dunking on for almost 20 years now
to say that Wolf Creek is a heroin movie
is a bit of an understatement it never
lets up with its unflinching depictions
of unspeakable violence nearly all of it
targeted against women this approach
divided critics who were torn between
thinking the craftsmanship on display
Justified the onslaught of misery and
feeling as though it was all just
torment with no underlying Point
audiences were significantly more
unanimous in their opinion on Wolf Creek
awarding the movie an F Cinema score
grade
though some filmmakers may have been
discouraged to see audiences so
thoroughly reject their work Wolf Creek
director Greg McLean held the movie's F
Cinema score grade up as a badge of
honor McLean explained to comicbook.com
in 2017 that the primary factor behind
Wolf Creek getting an app rating was
that it was so different from
traditional horror fair to see
moviegoers so viscerally respond to what
was happening on screen that they could
only respond with an F made McLean quite
proud plus McLean considers Cinema score
grades more of a reflection of whether
or not moviegoers got their previewing
expectations met rather than a microcosm
of a motion picture's actual quality of
Merit since its release the 2006
Nicholas Cage horror film The Wicker man
has inspired plenty of Joy thanks to
rampant internet memes based on its most
ludicrous moments
in these small out of context bursts of
absurdist Internet material the Wicker
man is a comedic Triumph as a
feature-length piece of Horus Cinema
though the Wicker man didn't please
anybody on its opening weekend
moviegoers dubbed the Wicker man worthy
of the lowest Cinema score grade it
wasn't just a handful of unintentionally
hilarious moments like cage running up
to punch somebody while in a bear outfit
a guaranteed wicker man such a
disastrous audience rating this horror
film also ended on a dark note
suggesting that every horrific thing the
papel Cage's protagonist would
inevitably happen again and again with
no end in sight without any concrete
resolution audiences felt cheated by
what they just witnessed it didn't help
that the original wicker Man movie is a
masterpiece of folk horror and the
reputation of that earlier feature
undoubtedly further highlighted the
already apparent flaws in this remake
however the Wicker man can at least take
mild comfort in knowing it inspired a
swarm of well-liked memes and will
undoubtedly be included in Cage's
extensive list of iconic performances
2007's bug can concerns a small group of
people gripped by paranoia that
escalates into violent delusions with
neither one truly Tethered to reality
there are no easy answers as to what is
real and what isn't just constant
uncertainty transporting viewers into
these paranoid mindsets this is a movie
meant to challenge moviegoers rather
than hand them easy answers on a plate
naturally this didn't go over well with
the general public especially with
previewing expectations a bug would be a
normal horror film that offered easily
digestible scares
oh get out opponents released at
theaters bug was hated by audiences even
critics accustomed to such artsy forays
and works at Ben genre Norms gave bug
mixed marks plus the film opened in May
2007 directly against more traditional
summertime pair like Pirates of the
Caribbean at World's End the hottest
months of the year are usually home to
movies that deliver plenty of surface
level spectacle and bugs stuck out like
a sore thumb in this release window
while the final moments leaving viewers
intentionally puzzled over what was real
in the preceding film and what was
Fiction it's easy to see how audiences
were overall miffed by what they sat
through movies never remain just movies
once they're put out into the world they
inevitably take on larger significance
beyond what the art is Behind These
works could have ever imagined so it was
with the 2007 erotic Thriller I know who
killed me this dark feature saw Lindsay
Lohan playing a woman struggling with
her identity in the wake of being
abducted and tortured
pill is Aubry on paper it wasn't a bad
idea for a film that could solidify
Lohan's gifts as an actor distinct from
her child star career in execution
though things went haywire before the
movie even came out it was already at
the center of tabloid reports obsessed
with every move Lohan was making but
Lohan's mid production rehab stint
dominating the pre-release headlines I
Know Who Killed Me needed to be a
masterpiece to evade all the toxic Buzz
unfortunately for everyone involved in
this movie it was far from that initial
critical reviews were disastrous an
audience is bestowed I know who killed
me with an F Cinema score grade it's
impossible to tell of all the
lohan-centric publicity heard the film's
audience reception but it couldn't have
helped if there's one so relining though
it's that the movie has garnered a
notable cult following in recent years
in hindsight it's baffling that
something like disaster movie was put
into theaters let alone given a massive
wide release while other parody movies
from directors Aaron Seltzer and Jason
Friedberg at least started with the idea
of spoofing a specific movie or genre
Disaster Movie just skewered a slew of
some 2008 titles that hadn't even come
out yet it was a barrage of
acknowledgments of other pop culture
properties instead of any actual comedy
a nadir for prodic filmmaking and Cinema
as a whole this feature landed a dreaded
F Cinema score grade a demonstration
that critics and audiences were in
lockstep on the quality of the comedic
disaster previous Seltzer and Friedberg
films weren't beloved by audiences but
even meet the Spartans was able to get a
c minus Disaster Movie fared even worse
for a multitude of reasons including the
use of incredibly creepy costumes for
dark versions of characters like Poe the
panda and its style of raunchy humor
trying awkwardly to fit into a PG-13
rating ultimately it's just a movie that
really didn't need to be made in the
2009 Richard Kelly movie The Box a
married couple are faced with an
enormous choice they can press a button
inside a box and get tons of money but
somebody in the world that they don't
know will die it's a moral quandary that
sends Elite characters down a rabbit
hole of conspiracy so convoluted that
it's no surprise the film hails from the
same mind behind Donnie Darko despite
this connection audiences had absolutely
no problem assigning a stinging upgrade
to the Box the movie Falls neatly into
the camp of many Motion Pictures that
receive the same grade it's a genre
exercise that offers lots of
inexplicable events to the viewer but no
explanations for what's going on by the
end of the Box this fictional Universe
has expanded to include the very fabric
of space and time itself not to mention
some Infamous water tombs it's all just
the sort of intentionally baffling
material that one would expect from
Richard Kelly but it's also guaranteed
to leave audiences frustrated rather
than satisfied one of the most infamous
movie endings of all time can be found
in the final Seconds Of The Devil Inside
which abruptly Cuts away from the
immediate aftermath of the main
character as being in a car accident to
a wall of text and forming moviegoers at
if they want more information on this
real case they should go to a website
link any potential dramatic resolution
to the story audiences have been
invested in for the last 80 minutes is
thrown out the window it's an incredibly
underwhelming conclusion and a downright
insult to the Integrity of Storytelling
needless to say is such an Abrupt
wrap-up did not go over well with
moviegoers while other aspects of the
devil inside inspired criticism this
conclusion proved especially divisive
and it being the last thing audiences
saw before exiting the theater
undoubtedly impacted this movie's Cinema
score grade the film's Dreadful Word of
Mouth helped ensure its rapid descent
from the top of the box office fittingly
this open-ended approach to concluding a
mainstream horror movie has not been
replicated in the years since the devil
inside frustrated audiences across the
globe before she took on the role of
Wanda maximoff in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe one of Elizabeth Olsen's very
first leading roles came in the micro
budget horror movie Silent House to make
sure this feature stood out from the
crowded pack of scary films out there
Silent House had the special flourish of
occurring in real time his story was
captured in a simulated single take a
gimmick had embraced long before Birdman
in 1917 strolled into town and became
Oscar Darlings such technical details
weren't enough to win over audiences
though who loudly proclaimed Silent
House was worthy of an app cinema score
grade the interesting wrinkle here is
that Silent House was not universally
Trashed by critics like most other
mainstream horror titles at get apps
they received mixed reviews but was far
from having no Defenders unfortunately
while its ambitious technical aspects
were enough to save Silent House from
Total critical dismissal its Bleak tone
and a barrage of strange narrative turns
in the second half undoubtedly alienated
the average moviegoer plus the Bose
single take filming gimmick was likely
puzzling and off-putting to many since a
film without cuts or alternating
perspectives can be a little too
immersive if you not ready for it
Killing Them Softly is a prime example
of a movie that should have leaned into
a theatrical run emphasizing Art House
theaters and audiences with those
moviegoers the film could have had a
chance to build up a better reputation
director Andrew Dominic's Bleak crime
drama which also functions as an equally
morose reflection on the optimism of the
Obama era is not an easy film to watch
nor is it meant to leave you feeling
enthralled it's a grimy motion picture
that offers up a mirror to our country
and audiences themselves right down to
its Unforgettable final line of dialogue
America is not a country
it's just a business
pay me naturally then the Weinstein
Company decided that because Killing
Them Softly was anchored by movie star
Brad Pitt it should be dropped into over
2400 theaters right in the middle of the
holiday season inevitably a film with
this release strategy marketed as just a
general crime drama was despised by
audiences they wanted something
traditional not subversive and angry
Killing Them Softly so missed the mark
in fulfilling audience expectations that
are received an upgrade from moviegoers
and almost immediately vanished from
movie theaters after its opening weekend
after 2012 the F Cinema score grade
remained silent for five years no new
wide release received such vicious
responses from the general public and
Studios didn't have to deal with an
abnormal audience score tanking a
movie's reputation online in September
2017 though that Hiatus came to a very
Vivid close with the premiere of mother
this was the newest release from
filmmaker Darren Aronofsky who's
preceding two directorial efforts Black
Swan and Noah each cracked the 100
million dollar Mark domestically such a
financial fate was not in the cards for
mother especially after it received an
Infamous f mark from audiences on its
opening weekend
family it's interesting that mother was
the next movie to get the F Cinema score
great after killing them softly since
both films are a bit similar each is
headlined by a big movie star in the
case of mother the iconic lead is
Jennifer Lawrence and each was marketed
as a bold new entry and a very
accessible genre however mother is not a
standard horror film it's a relentlessly
dark movie drenched in religious
symbolism that culminates in a baby
getting ripped apart on screen and
Lawrence getting physically abused while
aronofsky's biblical allegory is
doubtlessly original still ended up
being a little too abstract and shocking
for mainstream audiences
hey
you gave it all away
after a career of turning and Stellar
performances in a variety of movies
across differing genres Andrea
risborough scored her first Oscar
nomination at the 95th academy awards
ceremony for her lead role in to Leslie
however in a career as long as hers it's
inevitable that she would end up in one
or two creative misfires one of her most
notable artistic missteps came just two
years before the premiere of two Leslie
with the 2020 horror remake The Grudge
which rise bro herself headlined she
wasn't the only notable name in the cast
of this new take on The Grudge universe
as the likes of Damian Bashir John Cho
Jackie Weaver and more were all
scattered throughout the film's
inexplicably Stacked Supporting Cast
unfortunately none of these impressive
performers was enough to win over any
favor from audiences several elements of
the future like its clumsily organized
non-linear narrative structure likely
put audiences in the mood to despise The
Grudge long before the credits began to
roll however a comically abrupt ending
that tosses in one more scare from out
of nowhere and implies the death of
riseborough's protagonist was enough to
inspire audience frustration and secure
The Grudges placed in the pantheon of f
Cinema score movie
maybe we should tear our eyes out so
that we can see them anymore perhaps we
all should have recognized that 2020
would be a dark year for movies since it
was a dark year for pretty much
everything January of that Infamous year
delivered not one but two separate
features that garnered F Cinema score
grades exempting the trio of features
that scored that grade in 2012. this
marked the first year since 2007 when
multiple movies were deemed worthy to be
given an upgrade a second feature to
score this dubious honor in 2020 was he
had another horror film surprise
surprise the Turning Stars Mackenzie
Davis as a woman who must watch over a
pair of kids these youngsters turned out
to be quite troubled souls and the
ancient house they inhabits is equally
disturbing the Turning eventually pulls
out a bunch of strange twists in its
final moments including a reveal that
the big chase scene set piece was all
just a vision in an attempt to keep
audience members on their toes Instead
This screenwriting decision just
irritated moviegoers and left them
unsatisfied plus the decision to go with
a PG-13 rating on this horror film in
short it couldn't even deliver lots of
gory deaths or memorable kill goals to
give viewers an extra jolt of adrenaline
the Turning failed miserably and it
combined with the grudge proved an
unfortunate harbinger of all the
problems that awaited cinematic
storytelling in 2020
[Music]